honestly most of the time when the women
have a gut feeling it's 90 percent of
the time right guys not so much guys
it's like 45 percent of the time my name
is Elizabeth I'm a private investigator
in Los Angeles my name is John I'm a
private investigator and I've been so
for about two and a half years a lot of
people hire PI's people from all walks
of life every race gender age I get a
lot of stories out of my job people ask
me if you crazy things happen to you you
know just cuz your private investigator
because you're in LA this is the land of
insanity it's so much fun here's one of
my horror stories this woman hired us to
see if her husband was cheating and she
calls us saying my husband's been acting
different he comes home really late at
night I have these weird feelings one of
his female friends who we've been
friends with for a long time has been
acting really strange lately and oh
really nice we had to go follow her
husband to see if he was cheating she
said okay my husband is going to this
restaurant by that time we already have
the description of what he looks like
they send us photos they send us
pictures of the car he would drive but a
lot of the times when they give us a
photo it's like a photo maybe from five
or 15 years ago you're trying to see if
this person and in person like looks
like he does in the photo I get to this
restaurant where she wants us to follow
her husband and I see the guy and I'm
like okay this is the guy this is
exactly him it looks just like him he's
got this goatee and he's sitting with
this woman and they're really flirty
well I get a seat over next to them and
you know I kind of have my camera and
you're being really discreet cuz you're
on your phone I'm sitting there for at
least 45 minutes and I'm getting so many
juicy things and they're cuddling up and
they're kissing and I am so excited
because I just broke this case it's done
the woman's gonna be still happy go to
meet with the woman she's actually
crying and okay I'm ready to see this
finally you set the camera down there
like you know your phone and okay here's
the video and here's what we saw and I
press play and she's crying all this
when she looks at it she goes what
that's not my husband I'm mortified
because I just thought I had done this
amazing job on this case and even the
woman who he was with looked exactly
like the subjects friend it was two
people two couples who looked almost
exact
like in the same restaurant at the same
time about a week later we caught him
for real I got the wrong people but she
was pretty impressed because she said
I've never seen anyone who looks so much
like my husband in my life it was my
first surveillance gig ever I had to set
up and stake out this house a young girl
was staying at and her parents were
concerned that she would be doing
something you know dangerous or illegal
and almost as soon as I pulled up I see
the subject leaving the house on foot
all of a sudden I'm on foot I'm walking
and I don't know where I'm walking this
subject goes first to a park known for
certain transactions to take place as
she sits down and just reads a book for
an hour and then she gets up and she
starts walking again she's walking
through high-end clothing and that sort
of thing and pokes her head
into a couple stores and I have to you
know enter these stores and maintain a
distance but it's a tight little store
and I'm not a guy who would walk into
these stores keeping an eye on the on
the subject and then she would leave so
I had to pick up the tail again and
follow her before I realized that a
couple hours have gone by my car is
eight or nine miles away I mean I barely
know where I am I'm in this environment
that where I stick out like a sore thumb
so now I look like the weird shady guy
she turns around about faces and and
begins to walk what appears to be back
towards the home where she was staying
and I tipped my hand at one point she
turned a corner I was trying to catch up
with her as I hit the corner she comes
walking back the other way so for a
split second we're right there staring
at one another but at that point I
realized I can't risk having that happen
again if she sees me a second time she
might know something is up I hopped in a
rideshare got back to the house and sure
enough saw her approaching the home at
the end of the day it turned out it was
just a young lady who wanted to you know
get out and see what the city was like
for a few days so it was a happy ending
to
you know a scary story for the parents
at least so I was on an investigation
the wife hired us and said I think my
husband's cheating and I was called to
be kind of debate we're called bait
girls to see if the guy's gonna bite and
cheat on his wife he did really fast and
while we were on our first date we were
sitting there and we were having dinner
and all the sudden he leans over to me
and he's like I have something to tell
you though and I was like okay any guys
you may not know this but I'm really
smart and I was like oh yeah obviously
you're really smart you know I'm
charming and all of that and he goes I
know my wife I think she's hired a
private investigator so I just had to
keep you know really close like oh
really and he goes yeah I know I think
she did and I was like oh nobody does
that that's crazy do people actually
hire PI's these days he was like yeah
yeah but I'm on to her and I was like oh
okay
on the third date he tells me I just
feel like you're actually a PI but
here's the thing I don't even care and I
still want to date you I was like
mortified I try to keep a straight face
like um no I'm I'm not I do social media
no no I never told him he had already
sent me enough photos that were
incriminating enough though to where you
know I was just gonna walk away it was
kind of funny honestly because I like
catching bad guys man it's fun
[Music]